hi my name is Michelle gala and I am a
junior in chemical engineering during
the research and filmin theorem group on
electrochemical ammonia production
Mariza this is important because ammonia
goes into all agricultural production in
the world in the form of fertilizer it
has fueled the steady growth of a world
population over the last hundred years
but the method we currently have
available of producing it has a very
large capital cost upwards of a billion
dollars per single plant and carries a
proportional penalty in terms of co2
emissions this is why we are trying to
utilize lithium's natural reactivity
towards gaseous nitrogen to produce
ammonia at ambient temperature and
pressure with oxygen as the only
byproduct of reaction we do so by
producing lithium nitride for metallic
lithium and nitrogen and then
hydrolyzing this compound forming
ammonia which has been released and
quantified and lithium ions which are
vent electrochemically plated as lithium
metal this process requires hydrogen
carriers of a proton source and this is
where my project comes in I am looking
at different compounds that can be used
for about purpose and trying to find
trends between them we identified free
groups of compounds some of them are
active in the process and produce
ammonia as is expected and reported in
previous literature but some of them do
not do that we divide them into two
categories for inactive and the hyper
active sources in active sources in some
way do not seem to activate lithium
towards reaction with nitrogen so the
new traditional reaction and do not give
any yield of ammonia produced and we are
now doing research trying to explain why
various because it's a very surprising
result because lithium reacts with
nitrogen by itself it shouldn't need to
be activated towards that another
interesting result we got is the
specific characteristics of an active
permanent sources and it turns out but
some of them are not exactly the same as
reported literature which means but very
small structural changes to the
molecules cause a big difference in the
reactivity in this system doing that
allowed us to optimize the ammonia
production
as a function of concentration and
choice of permanent source leading to
significant improvements in faraday
efficiencies of produced ammonia using
especially and Brunel's or prone source
thank you